I mean you look at a movie now based at
list if it was 18 producers that's not
out of the ordinary I've been in the
business 50 years I have no idea what a
producer does so here we are on the
Sunday special with David Mamet
America's greatest living playwright and
screenwriter and the author of a
brand-new book called Chicago we'll get
right into it with mr. Mamet and just
one second first let's talk about your
impending death so you're gonna die soon
we all know it you know it hopefully not
that soon but soon enough that you
probably want life insurance 71% of
people say they need life insurance only
59% to actually have coverage which
means 12% of you are procrastinating
another 29% of you are idiots for
thinking you don't need life insurance
because you do normally procrastinating
is a bad thing but if you have been
avoiding getting life insurance
procrastinating may actually be working
in your favor because while you are
getting life insurance or not getting a
life insurance policy genius was making
it easy policy genius is the only way
and the easy way to compare the life
insurance online you can compare quotes
in just five minutes when it's that easy
putting it off becomes a lot harder you
can compare quotes while sitting on the
couch watching TV you can compare quotes
while listening to this podcast try it
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance and renter's
insurance and health insurance so if you
care about any of that they can cover it
if you need life insurance we've been
putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't have the time
checkout policy genius it's the easy way
to compare top insurers find the best
value for you no sales pressure zero
hassle and it's free policy genius com
go check it out right now ok David Mamet
thanks so much for stopping by really
appreciate it you're welcome so for
folks who don't know David's mom David
Mamet's work because they've been hiding
under a rock for the last Oh 40 years of
American screenwriting and playwriting
David Mamet is America's foremost living
American playwright and screenwriter
he's the if you ever seen the
untouchables he's the guy who did it
have you ever seen Glengarry Glen Ross
he's the guy who did it and he has a
brand new book out called Chicago which
is a gangster novel and it really is
fantastic you're gonna want to check it
out so David let's start from the very
beginning how did you get into
playwriting screen right how did you get
into writing from the very start well I
was a nerdy weld kid and you know I used
to teach a lot of colleges and they'd
say
want to have a special group of kids who
just want to talk to you so how would
you like us to pick them so I'd always
say well just give me the NER duels
because that the only people ever going
to amount to anything
but the college was never capable of
doing that because of course they're set
up to put the imprimatur on people who
can tell him on Wednesday what it was a
teacher stole him on Monday but I was a
class clown I never opened a school book
and people used to tell me nobody likes
a smartass
but that was the first encounter with
the authority where I knew they're just
dead wrong
right and they're making a difference if
nobody liked the smartass at all because
I was the only choice I had so that's
how I started on okay and so where did
you grow up I mean how did you what were
your parents like I grew up on the south
side of Chicago and my parents were
first-generation Americans their
grandparents are still alive they were
all Ashkenazi immigrants they all spoke
with a wonderful thick accent and I
guess you don't hear anymore and my
grandmother raised my dad as a single
mom didn't speak very very good English
and they were just marvelous people so
my mom and dad grew up they courted
during World War Two they got married
right afterward and my dad bought a
house in st. called Park Forest Illinois
which was the first plan the community
was before Levittown and it was houses
half the size of this the studio over
there and so then we moved to the south
side and I grew up on the south side of
Chicago okay and where did you go to
college and and when did you actually
start the writing was it in high school
when you were being a class clown or how
did that get started well I started
writing in high school and I actually
covered sports for the Park Forest star
they paid me like 4 bucks to cover the
high school sports I run for them and
then I wrote for my other high school
literary magazine and I went to college
and it was a hippie dippie school called
Goddard College in the middle of Vermont
and there was no school there I mean
there was literally no school there
because all the kids of the baby boom
generation were trying to go to college
and trying to stay out of Vietnam and
the school expanded so rapidly that
there were no dormitories and there are
no classrooms so they housed us in
northern Vermont in these little cabins
tourist cabins literally we
found any heat and we had to hitchhike
everyday eight miles to this abandoned
town hall where there were no classes so
that was that was interesting okay and
he started writing there and you were
writing your own plays or or well yeah
you know what is a kid in Chicago I was
connected with second city which was the
first improvisational theatre group
after the compass compass was Elaine May
Shelley Berman and Mike Nichols then it
became second city and so as a teenager
13 14 15 years old I worked there as a
piano player for the kid shows and I
worked as a busboy and so I used to
watch these great comics every night
doing sets right one after the other and
everything was a seven-minute blackout
and then I started reading plays and I
read that the people that really most
influenced me were check off and the
Pinter because I realized what Pinter
and check off were doing was exactly the
same thing they're doing at Second City
they were saying life is a serial comic
sketch and I'm gonna be able to reduce
life to seven-minute scenes which is
basically the lanten length of any scene
and Missy if I can make you laugh and
cry because of the ineffable wackiness
of existence so I discovered this and
said I know how to do that right it's
just like second city it's a blackout
sketch so I started writing sketches
then I wrote sketches while I was at
college and one thing led to another
well one of the things you're obviously
very well known for is the the
hard-nosed nature of your writing the
fact that everything you write has a
real edge to it that's not a pun about
movie wrote called the edge but it
actually is true that when you read your
writing it's very edgy stuff
where'd that hard-nosed sensibility come
from well I mean not everything I not
not everything I write is in the is in
the diana dilation vein i manifested in
the whole bunch of Apollonian
but um I guess I say I grew up in a
South Side and I my dad did very well of
eventually and it was an as a lawyer
we were staunch middle-class family and
I was a nice Jewish boy
but then I never any money I got out of
college so I started working at
everything in the world so to support
myself so I got a chance to hang out to
be part of the of the
working-class life of Chicago and and
you've written a lot about Chicago
obviously that's that's your new book is
about Chicago but it's a period piece I
mean this is obviously written about the
Prohibition era in Chicago with all the
gangsters it's sort of going over some
of the same period time as as
Untouchables what about that time did
you find so attractive writing about it
obviously we revisited it well then you
grew up in Chicago at least a big old
days you know 50 60 years ago the the
ethos of the Chicago was came out of the
gangster era and everybody talked about
the gangsters everybody knew somebody
you knew got Al Capone everybody had an
uncle who was maybe a little bit bent
that maybe your dad or mom had been a
little bit bent and Chicago was a
machine town right which is things got
fixed after you went up and saw the
captain as we used to say and if you
didn't go up and step up and see the
captain and turn out the vote or kick
back two weeks of your salary which
happen to my stepsister she got a job
working on the Illinois toll road and
she came back one day they want me to
kick back two weeks of my salary and
everyone said yeah so she's like
somebody said who wants to live in a
tunnel you can't fix a parking ticket
you know it did Chicago work yeah you
know if you were white guys Chicago work
pretty well now it doesn't work at all I
mean it works better if you're a white
guy than if you're getting killed on the
south side but it was a working man's
town it was a machine town and become
clear that if you want the government to
do something for you you got to do
something for them so that was the
Chicago Way yeah and then that's that's
something even I knew about my parents
are both from Chicago and it was when my
dad was growing up there he said was
still the kind of place where you could
wrap a $20 bill around your around your
ID when we were pulled over for a
traffic stop and you might be able to
get away with it oh yeah definitely I
mean we were getting it I used to play
as a cab driver getting harassed by the
cops all the time I sure that that's
that's completely changed so so let's
talk a little bit about your political
point of view because of late you've
been in some political controversies in
the last few years
you're obviously incredibly well known
for your writing and that means that a
lot of people who are on the Left a lot
of critics who tend to be on the
political left
we're very complementary if you work for
years and years and years do you find
that since you've become more overtly
conservative politically that that's had
any impact on how the critic street
worker they've been fair
all the critics are never fair I mean
that's what critics are you know I'm
working my side of the street that work
in theirs
and if you're a writer it's a perfect
example of free market right
I could spend one I might spend that
afternoon writing an act or 15 years
writing a play you don't even care right
all they know is the price of the ticket
right they might say I like her they
don't like it I don't have the right to
ask them why right so it if they don't
like it that's 15 years down the drain
especially in the theater it opens in
New York they don't like it you did
so interjected into this as all human
endeavors are hangers-on and parasites
and camp followers which is what critics
have traditionally been they've been you
know some good willed people I was the
beneficiary of a lot of goodwill and for
example from Roger Ebert and also from
Richard Kristensen Chicago's Belly News
and The Tribune but most critics are
they say what do you need to do to be
able to write dramatic criticism you
need to have a lack of talent to my
sports so that's true so some people who
do they get cross decked over the right
dramatic criticism and generally they've
been the bane of my existence I mean III
get it
all right there's always accidents at a
picnic sometimes they come down on my
favorite sometimes they came down the
other side but trying to be a good Jew I
say wait a second you know if I'm gonna
crash when they when they toss my work
unto the ash heap I shouldn't read the
the other reviews which I know through
my sixth bad sense are good generally
the the you can't survive in the United
States as a playwright until you please
the people in New York and since a
political conversion the press in New
York is especially the New York Times
has been vicious about and a as a
peremptory challenge in effect and in
effect I wrote this book which is
everybody's best seller list and the
question is harder the New York Times to
review it and the answer is that they
didn't they just chose not to okay so
as they used to say in the 19th century
the doctors used to say we have to wait
and let the disease declare itself so as
we've seen now in our country
politically the disease has declared
itself because this talk about your
politics were you always politically
conservative did you sort of find
yourself on the political right how did
you end up identified as somebody who is
politically conservative Republican if
you're comfortable with that label and
where do you find it what is your
political life well you know seriously I
think of a complete conservative in a
strict constitutionalist but when you
say the Republican my blood runs cold
because everybody I ever knew and
everybody who they ever knew was a
Roosevelt Democrat right under guide the
Republicans with the guys were you know
with the with the white plastic belts of
playing golf that you know at the
Country Club but I wrote a political
play and wasn't a political play was a
farce it was called November and it's
about a president who's about to get
kicked out of office because his what he
called approval ratings as he says
they're lower than Gandhi's cholesterol
okay he's about to get kicked out of
office and so he has this plan where
he's gonna it's both young elections
coming up and Thanksgivings coming up so
he's gonna pardon all the turkeys and
hold up the turkey I saw is a really
funny play so the New York Times back in
those days they were still speaking to
me oh by the way NPR decided I was a
non-person to about ten years ago but
Scott Simon just recently came came back
and said you know come on do my show
said it was very nice of him so they're
doing my play November on Broadway's
hysterically funny so they asked me to
write a piece for the New York Times
because back in the days when I was a
pre non person that's what they did if
you were so I wrote a play a piece for
your that's called political civility
based very much on the teachings of my
great friend and a great teacher rabbi
mordechai Finley and he said okay we
certainly peace we have to be civil to
each other I said we have to be able to
state the other person's point of view
in such a way they say yes that's what I
mean and then they asked me and after
and they and I have to be able to stay
at their point if you may say is what I
mean and
we're gonna reduce facts upon which we
can agree you said we can't agree on the
term off the table all we're gonna have
the table is facts upon which we agree
and then we'll reason from those facts
and if I come let us reason together to
see if we can arrive at some mutual
understanding so I wrote this a thing
about political civility and I said I
find it's also important to be civil to
myself because all my life have referred
to myself as a brain-dead liberal I said
you know there's a lot of truth in jokes
so I I said I have to stop and say wait
a second
why are you maligning yourself is is
this a platform of something which you
believe or not you know isn't this great
middle-of-the-road peace blah blah blah
new york times you know as we say we we
can deal with the christians god help us
with the german jews right so i wrote
the piece for a weason was for The
Village Voice we're ready for the The
Village Voice meanwhile New York Times
come out and give it play a terrible
review so the Village Voice takes this
piece I called political civility and
they retitle it why I am no longer a
brain-dead liberal for a front page okay
kaboom New York Times comes back and re
reviews the play November gives a worst
review and I find myself I find myself
out in the cold and I said well ok I got
to figure this out so I sat down for a
couple years and I wrote a book called
of the secret knowledge about politics
and did a whole lot of reading a whole
lot of thinking trying to reason my way
through to an understanding of the
political process which hurt like hell
because I had to recognize that what I
had accepted is the way things are were
simply prejudices and examined them to
see if I could hope to see if there was
any truth in them or not so I wrote that
book and I found that my friends turned
into acquaintances and you know my
cranes across the street and Ruth Weiss
said something great about the great
Ruth Weiss somebody at Harvard said you
know dr. Weiss what will I do if I tell
people what I really
think what will happen to me and root
said you'll be free so we'll talk about
that in just one second first let's talk
about your freedom from internet
intrusion with all the recent news about
online security breaches it's hard not
to worry about where my data goes making
an online purchase simply accessing your
email could put your private information
at risk you are being tracked online by
social media sites and marketing
companies your mobile or internet
provider not only can they record your
browsing history they often sell it to
other corporations who want a profit
from your information which is why I've
decided to take back my privacy by using
expressvpn expressvpn has easy to use
apps that run seamlessly in the
background of my computer phone and
tablet turning on expressvpn protection
only takes one click so here's how it
works
expressvpn secures and anonymizes your
internet browsing by encrypting your
data hiding that public IP address and
you can protect yourself with expressvpn
for less than seven bucks a month
yes expressvpn is rated the number one
VPN service by TechRadar it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee so if you
ever use public Wi-Fi you want to keep
hackers and spies from seeing that data
expressvpn is the solution and if you
don't want to hand over your online
history to your internet provider or
data resellers
that's what expressvpn is there to do
protect your online activity today find
out how you can get three months for
free and expressvpn comm slash Ben
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with the one-year
package is it expressive VPN calm slash
Ben to learn more okay so in the secret
knowledge what what did you actually
discover when you delved into the
political system and and you say that
you learned some things that you hadn't
thought about before what exactly were
those things that hadn't occurred to you
well nothing had occurred to me because
there was a red diaper baby and grew up
in the bubble you know it was great to
hate all the Republicans and great to be
a peacenik and great at all these things
what I went back on what I understood I
think was the the the biblical
underpinnings of the Declaration on the
Constitution which basically goes back
to the Torah on one foot right if it's
hateful to you don't do it to your
neighbor that's it
so I said the reason why way back to the
bare metal if you would and what I came
up with was that the Constitution is a
compact among thieves
it's people to say you know I know I'm
not a very good person I try but I fail
I know you're not either let's see if we
can agree
on the the least amount of rules it
would get us free of King George the
third and I was to keep an eagle eye on
each other to allow us freedom from
government so this was a concept that
you know I might have heard the phrase
we didn't saw what it meant but then I
started thinking I said well wait a
second every time you get a letter in
the in the mail and that dress is any
governmental agency what's the first
thing you feel it's fear its fear and
then they wanted to tear it down my
hedge in Santa Monica so he bought this
house like 20 years got this big old
hedge right wonderful had great complete
privacy marvelous we got a thing in the
mail it says you were in violation of
1943 edge law no no hedge can be more
than three feet tall you if you don't
cut down your hedge immediately we'll
charge you get this $25,000 a day so I
start going to the City Council people
are weeping weep weep weep you know my
grandfather planted a heads
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo I start looking into
it they're going broke city of Santa
Monica like brokers all or all the
liberal communities because they text
business away okay so they figure how
can I make money you comb through all
the laws and find something that you can
in the force
so everybody fights them they fight them
in the court this it's unconstitutional
it's never of you can't find somebody
$25,000 before it's been adjudicated
then law was never enforced so what they
come up with is this they say okay
anybody who had a hedge that's been
there for 22 years or more and you can
prove it through the blah
you can keep your hedge but we now have
a new organization which is the hedge
police and the hedge police will come
every year and they will take a
surveyors transit to make sure that the
hedge is not higher than it was 22 years
ago
that's thing this is all government
there's like I said in my kids all
government comes down to the hedge
police well it's really interesting
because when you watch your movies
they're they're a lot of and see some
your place when when you when you
there's some lines that have become just
part of sort of the American parlance
obviously there's the whole Chicago ways
speech from The Untouchables or the or
the speech that in the movie version
Alec Baldwin gives in Clinton Glengarry
Glen Ross be always be closing speech
and a lot of folks on the left-hand to
use these particular lines actually a
fair bit so Barack Obama famously
suggested that you don't bring a knife
to a gunfight it's in his sort of
political heyday and people on the Left
are constantly suggesting the capitalism
is this dog-eat-dog business where
people are attempting to tear each other
down then they use that as an excuse for
government intervention ISM but it
sounds like you know your basic view of
human beings that all human beings are
basically at each other and that's why
we have to come to these basic
agreements to leave each other alone
well yeah I was watching yesterday that
the great Tucker Carlson I'm crazy about
him he had some cockamamy I think
Democrat something or other and you know
uh congressman like that and he says to
the guide Democrats as we second he says
you guys got nothing left in a golf bag
so what in the world are you gonna run
on in the midterms and the guy says
economic justice and social justice so I
said well ok you know let's let's break
it down to being of the English language
right what does economic justice mean at
the end how's that different than
justice right
it's communism what it means it's
somewhat it's statism it means that
someone is going to stand above whatever
rules we have for commerce and decide
what's just to whom right so as you know
some soul said once every ever anybody
says it's gonna help a you say well
who's gonna hurt right so economic
justice is at the end of the day it's
communism it's saying and communism if
someone's gonna be in charge of saying
what you have to give to me and I'll
keep I'll keep what I think I want and
give it back to you which brings me back
to when I realized that the whole the
the Marxian idea from each according to
his ability to each according to his
need really begs the question because
the term which is missing is the state
shall take from each according to his
ability which means the state's going to
determine what your ability is the state
shall give to each according to his name
I'm
State I'm gonna determine what you need
you don't determine it anymore you don't
determine what your abilities the state
does so so much for economic justice I
thought social justice how's that
different than decaf justice right right
get a common garden decaf justice right
so justice is drawing a line that's what
justice is like taking a line of type
and justifying it I'm gonna say this is
in that's out is there gonna be
injustice in terms of Justin yeah sure
the Talmud says right where there's law
there's injustice okay great we're gonna
have a line right social justice means
there's no line whoever's screaming
loudest gets to say this is what you
have to do so you say wait a second
let's refer to the line let's refer to
the law they say no no throw out that
law the law is insufficient and they got
a guy talking to it Shirley said well
obviously the Constitution's on a date
how would a 2238 forty year document
possibly be relevant I didn't want to
say well then why are we sitting here
reading the Torah but so what I said was
wait a second okay let's say it's out of
date how are you gonna fix it what do
you suggest and more importantly what
are the rules by which you suggest we're
going to set it said go about fixing it
because social justice is fascism that's
what it means it means that the group of
people who has screams the loudest gets
to determine what the law is and that
always ends in murder so that's a
they're too wonderful of phrases
economic justice and social justice
which don't mean nothing as the Samantha
sness which would tell us they mean
something and what they was the first
thing they do is they're an anaesthetic
so so he'll how much should politics
play into the art that you make you sit
down to write a book you sit down to
write a play or a movie how do you
filter out your politics or you just
sort of let it flow does it just sort of
well I myself the main thing is like in
the last hour that they I have to stop
listening to Mark Levin that's that's
the main thing he's a pretty smart guy
but I you know he gets tired and so I he
gets an irate and I get irate so the
main thing is for me is listen to the
radio a lot less read the newspaper a
lot less and I spent like a last couple
of years writing s political essays
and I just said to my assist you know
phylum I mean Birnam if you want to like
I know what I think nobody else really
cares what the what I think let me get
on wouldn't be going back to being a gag
writer see if I can make people laugh
once in a while one of the things that's
driven people on the right absolutely
insane is obviously dominance of the
left in the cultural sphere and my good
friend Andrew Breitbart who I think you
knew Andrew was fond of saying that
culture is upstream of politics the more
people are shaped in the country by sort
of the culture with which they engage
television movies entertainment because
we spend a lot more time engaging with
that content than we do with political
content do you think that's true you
think you know there's a guy wrote a
book up was there was Paul Ingrassia and
he wrote a book I believe called crash
course or crashed something about the
merger of Chrysler and Fiat right and
what he says in that book is really
important to me he says culture will
outdo organization every time because
culture is the oral torah right weapon
which there were you know our
understanding of the written Torah is
based now so my wife is every year she
goes back to visit the old folks at home
in Scotland so I spent like three weeks
alone forgiving her okay so I was
watching a Turner Classic Movies a love
old movies right but they ran out of old
movies so they're running like Lassie
Come Home / - you know although that I
just I get it already how many times can
you watch Lawrence of Arabia so I
started writing I started looking at
on-demand movies right new releases
on-demand movies and I've just seen a
couple good movies over less than you
most of these movies are garbage and not
only if they garbage there a certain
thereof form of cultural obscenity
because they're either
kiss kiss or bang bang they're either
simulated a non simulated sex or there
there's a sato mystic as the
sadomasochistic fantasy of violence so
I'm thinking well okay
left right okay Hollywood if you're
really interested in not mistreating
women don't do it don't do the sex scene
not knock it off learn how to write for
the love of right because that's why the
sex scenes in it cuz people get right I
say if you're really interested in doing
away with gun violence why do you have a
gun in every poster of every
he ever made where people shooting each
other why are they carving each other up
well the reason is that the people who
write these things don't have any I
don't have any skin in the game as they
can't write very well so if they don't
get any joy out of figuring out a plot
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
put you know it offs meat tenderizer and
everything which is either sex or
violence how do you think that that
impacts the the culture do you think
that that has an impact on politics more
generally or do you think that it sort
of just the background noise like when
people go to see a movie do you think
that that actually has the capacity to
shift how people think no no no
absolutely you know well I don't know
but that's good it's good question cuz
it it doesn't have a capacity to make
people better which is the other
obscenity that moves you're supposed to
raise our consciousness right but they
saying deaf people are people to black
people of people to gay people of people
the only people who aren't people to
you'll notice of the Jews that we Jews
are not people too but nonetheless so
the movies don't make people better so
the question is I think hydraulically I
have to say do movies make people worse
I got to say probably not with all of
that said do you think that the
obsession that people on the right have
with sort of left-leaning and bias in
Hollywood do you think that's overstated
because if it turns out that culture
doesn't really change people's minds on
various issues or play into politics all
that much
should we stop worrying about the sort
of movies that we see quite so much or
should we kind of let it go or is it
something that the right has a reason to
be obsessed with and upset about well
what are you gonna do about it I mean
what what concerns me is black listing
in Hollywood because I think you know
I've been in show business for 50 years
and most people my family are in show
business and I don't know what their
politics are but I know that that I get
tails all the time of and people come up
to me on the street and they'll say Oh
mr. mammoth and they'll whisper but say
you know I read your book I don't know a
man that's sick I mean because everybody
who's not above the line which is to say
a featured player in Hollywood is in the
closet if they were conservative because
they'd lose their job yep and and I
wrote a 400 page book actually
specifically about this it was very
funny I went into all of these producers
in town wearing a Harvard Law baseball
cap with the last name Shapiro and they
obviously assumed that I was on the left
and then I would ask them questions
about whether
they discriminated against conservatives
in Hollywood until fire people will try
to make sure that nobody can get a job
if they're on the other side of the app
here's my theory my theory is that
because the left has taken over the
commanding heights of culture because
they've basically decided they're gonna
sneer down their nose and everybody who
disagrees with them the entire middle of
the country that because of that the
right has responded by saying we're
going to respond politically we're gonna
we're going to take over the politics of
the country in response to you because
we're so angry but we can't take over
Hollywood but we can do is vote we can
definitely vote we can get out then we
can vote our people in and then the left
response to those votes by getting even
more angry and making the culture even
more degraded it used to be that there
was a common culture we all shared back
in the 1950s where people only had three
channels or do channels and and we all
watched the same sort of stuff and we
all watched the same sort of movies
there was a common background to our
culture and now the culture has
fragmented but is essentially to the
left and people have responded to that
left-leaning culture with a right-wing
politics do you think that there is any
hope that culture is infiltrated by
conservatives anytime soon or that we
come back together do you think the
political split is just going to get
worse exacerbated by culture well it's a
good question I don't know I mean I'm
not that concerned about Hollywood
culture I'm very very concerned about
education but there seems to be maybe
I'm crazy a little bit of groundswell
under the pre Millennials of the saying
wait a second let me think about this
you know and I don't want to had my head
stuffed full of trash I don't know I
always thought as I get older that's not
that people change but gravity' that
they die so that my generation or one
generation passes away another
generation comes up but the earth it's
bite if global warming haha and ders
forever so there's a new generation
that's coming out of the out of the
center of the country and out of younger
people and we're going to have a
different Supreme Court and eventually
the people on the Left have to stop
screaming I mean I don't know what their
their program for this wonderful country
is other than hatred of Donald Trump
that's not a program it is an amazing
thing I mean you and I were having lunch
or brunch over in Santa Monica area and
we were sitting there and I've serviced
two friends that we were sitting there
and it's beautiful I mean it's a really
nice restaurant no lights streaming in
I'm having a coke and you're having
lunch
and everybody around is having $200
bottles of Chardonnay sitting there
playing with they're playing with their
iPhones in the most prosperous freest
country in the history of the world and
if we take in a poll of the room people
would have thought that we are living in
the shadow of looming tyranny when in
reality we're living as close to a
heavenly existence as it's possible to
live on this earth if you plunked
somebody out from 1900 and plunked them
down right here aside from the general
lack of values I think that those people
would look around and go wait a second
if I have a baby now I can expect that
baby to live till 80 years old if I have
a kid right now I don't have to worry
about that kid dying in infancy and I'm
going to survive childbirth and yet here
we are sitting in the richest area of
the richest neighborhood in the country
and everybody if you would pull the room
they would think that we were living in
buy more Germany and the whole things
about to collapse well they're enjoying
it I mean god bless him you know but as
they say people don't believe in
something will believe in anything here
here's where I think he'd go to the
newsstand it was watching walk
ambassador stand today Newsweek magazine
the terrible news is on the cover as a
picture of Betsy DeVos right has devoted
her life and her fortune to education
and it says Betsy divorces war on
teachers right that's the bad news the
good news is Newsweek magazine is now
this thin right the week before is
Donald Trump you know looking down at a
child who's weeping you know a phony
together photo montage it's the bad news
the good news is Time magazine is now
that then there's now three people who
subscribe to the New York Times and I
think two of them have parrots so things
are changing now you're optimistic for
the future of the country or do you
think they do yeah I feel incredible you
know somebody said a long time ago I
said no a democracy survives more than
300 years so I think that this news
shift to a constitutional republic
toward a constitutional constitutional
republic is going to lengthen the
viability of the American experiment by
50 to a hundred years that's what I
think what do you think I mean I'm a
little pessimistic then you just because
I feel like the pendulum swings pretty
far in this country and and it's swung
from Barack Obama to Donald Trump which
means that it's gonna swing back even
further to the left the next time around
just because the Democratic Party by
default has made
itself into a Democratic Socialist Party
kind of a European Democratic Socialist
Party and so when the pendulum swings
it's gonna swing back toward a Bernie
Sanders or an Alexandra Ocasio cortes at
least temporarily and that's not good
for the country I don't think that there
are a lot of substantive conversations
being had because people are so angry at
each other and I do think that has to do
with the lack of a common base of values
like it sounds like when you were
growing up you were growing up with the
feeling that despite all the corruption
in Chicago if you worked hard you could
get ahead and it was actually your
obligation as a decent human being to
work hard and make something of yourself
and I feel like there are entire
generations of people in this country
who have been raised on the premise that
America is actually a terrible place
that is seeking to put its boot on your
throat and then anyone who proclaims
that America is good is a perpetuator of
this evil system that's true but all
these generations who were raised in the
bobo I don't think Starbucks can can
open outlets sufficiently enough to keep
pace with that growing population so
what are you gonna do for living after
their parents diner you know they're
sitting on the couch and working as a
bar wrist I don't get it well then
that's the big question and I do wonder
you know whether these folks have a
skill set they they don't I mean that's
the other thing that gets me if there's
and I talk to have a lot of kids I mean
I I want to go live in a shoe with the
old woman that's how many kids I have
but the way we talk a lot and I talked
to them and some of them experienced the
great joy of doing something for living
yeah I mean it's it but I don't know
that they're that many people in the
United States who actually see that I
mean they see they see oh there are too
many people I there and maybe I'm the
pessimist here but I see a lot of people
in the United States who see work as
something to be avoided like they
attribute all of their stress to work
work is always a bad thing when they
talk about things in their life that
they want to get over it's work and you
know for me my goal is to work until I
die because that's usually how it works
the minute you retire you're going right
so yeah my belief is sort of the belief
from the from the book of Genesis which
is that you are put on the earth to
cultivate it and the minute you stop
cultivating it there's no reason for you
to be here anymore but I think that
there are a lot of people who actually
believed that they were put on here here
on earth for leisure time and enjoyment
and the more that we require of you the
harder you have to work that's an
inherent flaw in the country that it
were according to Bernie Sanders logic
we're so rich why should anybody have to
work well Bernice I think I met him in
you
because I spent a lot of time with about
the same age overlapping in North
Central Vermont I don't think he's ever
worked a day in his life
so literally he hasn't I mean he was
kicked out of a communist are mine
legitimately it's the actual thing that
happened and now he owns a lake house
right so it's a great country where you
can never work a day in your life and
have a lake house where you vacation
with Bill DeBlasio
well the question is worded the question
is which the younger won't address is
where's the money come from
they say from the government well all
the government can do is is either tax
you or steal it from you or waste that
or spend money on either things that
everybody needs but nobody wants to pay
for or things that nobody wants those
are the only two things the government
can spend the money on so the young
person doesn't say where does the money
come from I mean what I worry about I'm
not sure that it's a that we have a
problem of economics as so much as you
know a lot of folks on the Left thinks
the problem of redistribution ISM in the
economic system and all this I really
don't think that's the problem I think
we do have a problem of virtue and art I
think they were really I think they're
there's a giant hole in the middle of
the American soul that has been carved
there by 40 50 years of dependence on
government and a belief that there is no
higher calling for you that your job on
this earth is basically to experience
the most pleasure possible and then die
and I don't know what replaces that
other than a return to some sort of
centralizing values well I don't know
either except that I have a difficult
time controlling myself I mean I want to
even attempt to try to control somebody
else gonna be what's gonna be oh yeah I
mean I'm not talking about compelling
people but I do think that the appeal of
a moral lifestyle has always been a hard
sell and it's it's a particularly hard
sell when there are no consequences to
immorality well there's a very good book
on the subject you know which is called
a Torah you know what's the consequences
for morality and say yeah it's a plague
or forty years in the desert or don't
think twice a month so let's talk about
you Jewish philosophy because you came
from he's had a red diaper doper baby
kind of background so your parents were
secular Jews they were very very secular
Jews and it didn't know that we went
they went to a Sunday School and I mean
let alone at Aulis you never saw a
yarmulke I mean someone would want a
yarmulke it was like these Episcopal
reformed temples it would have been
lynched and I thought a lot about it two
things occurred me
one is that Arthur Hertzberg in his
wonderful book the Jews in America talks
about the Ashkenazi abandonment that the
that at least a quarter maybe more the
quarter of the men who came over
abandoned their wives she couldn't take
it which is a huge secret among the
Ashkenazi community and it happened to
my dad and his dad came over from
Russian Poland just left them and so my
grandmother's secret single woman hardly
spoke English raised two kids during the
Depression but if you said to your dad
my dad oh you know your dad a band he
said no no he didn't abandon me and I
always knew where he was
so this hertzberg says it was the the
father who took the kids to show so what
the father is not there who's taking the
kids to show the other thing about a
simulator 'lest reform was the bee's
knees the young people wanted to be
American but he didn't want to be
European they wanted to be American
being Jews was was tough and they
encountered a lot of anti-semitism in
those days and then if that weren't bad
enough Europe killed all the Jews right
so if there's no upside to being a Jew
which is Judaism and the Torah and the
wonderful Yiddish gite all there is his
downside so the people in my Episcopal
reformed upbringing went to Temple the
same way one might go to the dentist
they say I don't want to but I know it's
good for me and you see that today and a
lot of the reformed synagogues around
here you know people will sit there you
know as if they're watching paint dry
and not and not and then give all their
money to the building fund so what do
you get out of it I mean you obviously
grew up in that environment what made
you kind of return to the value of the
Torah was it allegiance to the Past was
it was an inherent value in the document
what what is it that you like about
about the Torah because obviously that's
not again a hard pitch for a lot of
young people today we're becoming an
increasingly secular society fewer young
people are going to church than ever
before in American history it's not true
you sure yeah the evangelicals and the
fundamentalist well no I mean among
evangelicals and fundamentalists it's
still a large number but overall the
number of young people who are going to
church has been steadily decline
for years for Jews it's always been like
eight of us among the among the Orthodox
it still remains high but everywhere
else in the Jewish community it's very
low what do you what is the strongest
pitch for taking the Bible seriously or
at least the values of the Bible
seriously well people should read them
and the only thing wrong with the Bible
is as we used to say there's not enough
pictures add more pictures on there
somebody you know is going to take that
idea and run with it
Villegas learn to hate but the wonderful
thing about the Bible is my teacher and
rabbi Adam what if I Finley says people
say is this what happened he says no
it's not what happens what always
happens so this is magnificent
compilation of folktales and literature
and how-to and humor and it's just it's
the history of the West and if you said
this was oh you know all the Jews they
used to call about the Judas right of
the Buddha Jews right they want to
become Buddhists they want to become
Wiccans they want because they're
searching for meaning of course they are
but there's a lot of that the meaning is
right there it's the history of our
people and what's what made America what
it is because all of these people they
read two books in their life a little
them they read the Bible they were the
collected works of Shakespeare and they
came up with the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution what
so when I was getting married to my
wonderful wife Rebecca and we she said
all we ever to have a Jewish wedding and
she was raised as my by a physicist and
a yoga teacher in Scotland so people
thought religion was nonsense but
generations back a lot of them and
Jewish she's we have to have a Jewish
wedding and I said okay why she's a
because so he found this great rabbi
rabbi Larry Kushner who's now in San
Francisco we started going to his show
in Sudbury Massachusetts and at one
point he said he said oh he said you
guys should really learn Hebrew I said
oh no no I learn Hebrew in foreign
language but he said no no no it's this
Biblical Hebrew simple he said if you
know on a scale of difficulty of English
is an aid in Hungarian is an ID and
Mandarin Chinese so ten Hebrews a two so
he taught us Hebrew said reading the
Bible in Hebrew send my god
but what a great them what a great gift
I'm actually going right back no one has
to interpret it to me
I'm going right back to the actual word
that was written 3000 years ago I think
way you say about the impact of biblical
kind of foundations on Western
civilization that's one of the reasons
why I don't think it's that people
reject the Bible and therefore they
reject kind of the American tradition in
the Western tradition I think they
reject the Western tradition in the
American tradition and therefore they
reject the Bible they don't like how
America turned out and they're upset
about things as they are and so they say
well then I don't like any of the
foundations for for America either it
seems like they're angry at the current
status it's not that they decide they're
gonna be secular and they don't believe
in the Bible it's that they decide that
America has too many flaws that it was
based on a bad system and that bad
system was based and turned on the Bible
and therefore we have to be against the
Bible if we want to build something
better which is sort of Marxist take on
history I think well yeah I mean and
also I mean I haven't been to a lot of
time I've been at church and decades but
I go to do a few synagogues around the
world and most of the Reformed
synagogues I mean I'd rather drop
bowling balls on my feet you know why
you say why I don't get it but isn't
this is nothing there so there are some
wonderful people among those with a
ghetto I mentioned my rabbi who was an
absolute genius so we go every week and
he talks about the Torah and bucks for a
couple hours on the Saturday and he is
an absolute genius says things that you
never never thought about before because
he's devoted his life to trying to
understand that document well
understanding history I think then as an
Orthodox Jew you know somebody takes it
very seriously understanding history
understanding where we came from I think
if you don't understand that history
you're not going to understand as you
say America and you're not going to
understand what makes America a
wonderful place and how we got to this
place in civilization in the first place
it's easy to pick off the fruit of the
tree after having burned down the trunk
which is I think what so many people are
trying to do right now I want to ask you
you mentioned earlier that you think the
writing in Hollywood the the quality of
it has declined number one why do you
think that is in number two if you had
to name five movies that are not your
own that you just love what would those
movies be well Galaxy Quest of course
the greatest movie ever made
and of course I loved the Super Troopers
I see they come out with Super Troopers
too I'm afraid to see it because a bike
seemed gone with the wind - I mean
can't do better collagen web the
godfathers the you know I think one of
the great one of the great gems of world
litter of film literature and I like the
killing by Stanley Kubrick and dodsworth
by William Wyler there was a little
marriage of convenience between so the
cinematograph the kinematic graph
started out as a carnival arcade right
you put a nickel in and showed you a
couple of pictures and the earliest
pictures were pictures of a train coming
toward you were people walking down the
thing will go ooh ah they were selling
um they were selling an experience
then they started as films in the late
teens went from being a 1 realer to
being a full-length movie they said
Jesus Christ you know we need a plot how
are we gonna do a plot we'll have a
story so they started filming stories
right and they started going they went
to a lot to novels they went a lot to
the theater they started doing stories
and then when sound came in 1920 28 like
that is okay I get it now we're
basically this was going to be a filmed
play then as movies progressed some
people got the idea wait a second this
is a whole new vocabulary we get to tell
the story in pictures and we get to have
dialogue and so you got the Golden Age
of Hollywood you know in the late 30s
and to the into the 40s of some
magnificent filmmakers who really
understood the capacity of film as a new
medium and for some reason the suits
weren't paying attention right so a lot
of good stuff got made then as film got
more and more became more and more big
business
the suits took over and they said wait a
second we the we we can't we have a
franchise we can't put this franchise in
jeopardy by having a plot so if you look
at the the the late 50s into the 60s
American movies and at the end into the
seventies versus European movies is
nothing very much happening you know
it's the big franchise you know it's
Doris Day as opposed to a Sophia Loren
so okay so now things start the
generating generating be generating
there they took all the back lot so they
just did this at Fox like five years ago
they had the last back lot I think left
on the west side and they tore it down
to put in parking structures for who for
whom them I mean you look at a movie now
based at list if it lists eighteen
producers that's not out of the ordinary
I've been in the business fifty years I
have no idea what a producer does and
zero
who are these producers right were there
people who are in charge of making sure
that we're going to keep the audience
rather than people who get a kick out of
making a movie so here's a question
because you mentioned sort of the 30s
and 40s and maybe early 50s is sort of
the golden era of movies and that of
course is a and not just a common
opinion I think that it's pretty well
accepted well how much do you think that
has to do with with going back to a
point you made earlier with about the
fact that right now every movie seems to
be very reliant on sex and violence and
basically from 1933 to 1960 the Hays
Code was in place thanks to thanks to
the Catholic Legion of decency saying we
don't want to see any of your sex and
violence yeah and say had to operate
around the rules and you know one of the
theories has basically been the one
there all these rules in place with
regard to writing that actually in some
ways makes the writing better because
you actually have to write around all
the stuff that otherwise would be
obvious what do you make of that that's
a very good question I really like the
pre-code movies as everybody does
because they're rougher you know the
code comes in and all of these you know
Ledger's and and pimps and blah
blah who then as now rule Hollywood said
oh I'm gonna get on my whole own high
horse so I can get out of here and snort
some coke and go have some illicit sex
there's a there's a great energy to the
pre-code movies but I don't know if
that's a causal relationship or just
things things got things got too rich
that people could not afford I'll tell
you a story a guy comes to me he says
from a big agency where he's trying to
lure me to the big agency and he says
listen he says we want you to write this
half-hour television show and it gives
me that idea I said thanks and pretty
good idea I don't wanna write it he says
wasn't you understand he says if you
write this
and it goes into syndication after 10
years you could get 10 million dollars
he said how long would it take you to
write a half-hour television show I
still take me about a half an hour he
said think about it I said I am thinking
what a waste and I said if it I get 10
million dollars a half-hour it's 20
million dollars an hour right that's 800
million dollars a week that's 4 billion
dollars a year if I take 2 weeks off he
says if you're making that kind of money
you couldn't afford to take two weeks
off so what do you make of the changes
to the industry right now so you know
the industry is obviously fragmenting a
lot of film is getting made not only
abroad but also by the various
independent producers and now it's being
aired on Netflix then the movie model
itself seems to be collapsing in on
itself it's very difficult for a star to
even hold a film anymore it just stars
don't have the same sort of cachet in
the United States that they used to are
you excited about the future of where
film is going or do you think that TV is
where it's at well what do you think the
entertainment industry is is going which
trend lines should we be following well
the only thing I'm excited about in my
latter years is taking a nap
so I'm going to let things go on without
me as they're as they will but if you
look at the 20th century entertainment
and the theater was always changing
right in vaudeville came in and the
people on stage looked down on
vaudeville and then movies came in and
the people on stage looked down at
movies and so this was the second tier
of stage actors who went into the movies
the same thing happened in radio Radio
command and the second tier of the the
stage people went into radio and then
television came in and those radio
people plus the second tier again from
movies went in the television they
became the huge stars as people who
basically see players and every
subsequent iteration of technology drove
the other one you know we don't have
much theater anymore you know except for
Mamma Mia and we don't have any
vaudeville anymore nobody listens to the
radio anymore and broadcast television
is all over right so now movies are
getting to be all over okay things
change so now we're going into the
we are definitely into electronic age
that people have been saying for 30
years wait until the first person
figures out how to monetize home video
and now it's here so I asked you earlier
about your favorite film so what are
your favorite plays obviously your
playwright as well
well what who do you think are the you
mentioned Pinter and check off before
but who are your favorite playwrights
and and favorite plays you named your
top five well I don't like going to the
theater because you there's no popcorn
so the thing about going to the movies
this is really great is you know if you
really like popcorn I love popcorn so
what do you do you eat down to the
bottom of the popcorn and you start
crunching the kernels because you can't
because it's the current it's the it's
the great human dilemma right I want
some more popcorn but I don't want to
shame myself by going back to the
popcorn thing again so I'm getting the
scene so what happens is the last little
bit of kernel you get that little thing
stuck in your teeth you know and so do
you spend the rest of the movie picking
that up so that the movie doesn't have
to be that interesting okay well you
know it's really a pleasure to have you
here and I'm so glad that you could make
the time folks if you've not read David
Mamet's latest book the book is Chicago
you should definitely go check it out it
really is it really moves I mean it's a
it's a book that definitely will keep
you awake all the way until the end of
it if thanks so much for stopping by it
really appreciated welcome
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy borin associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens edited by Alex singhara audio is
mixed by Mike Carr Amina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah of era and title graphics
by Cynthia and gula the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]